aquí tenemos una serie infinita y la
meta de este vídeo es tratar de
encontrar el intervalo de convergencia
de esta serie esta es otra forma de
decir que el rango de valores de x va a
converger esta serie y como siempre los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolver esto por su cuenta
sirve en esta serie pues no coincide
exactamente con una serie geométrica o
con una serie alternante cuando veo algo
así pienso en el criterio de la razón ya
que tiende a ser bastante general y para
aplicar el criterio de la razón queremos
pensar en el límite cuando n tiende al
infinito del término n 1 dividido entre
el enésimo término el valor absoluto de
esto sí esto es menor que 1 entonces va
a converger y los valores de x que hagan
que esto sea mayor que 1 entonces esto
divergen y para los valores de x que
hagan que esto sea igual a 1 pues
entonces no tendremos una respuesta no
sabremos si esto converge o diverge
por lo que tendremos que usar otras
técnicas para saber si esto converge o
divergen pensemos en esto vamos a
evaluarlo el límite cuando n tiende al
infinito del valor absoluto de a su n 1
esto va a ser x a la n 1 entre n 1 x 5 a
la n 1 y esto lo vamos a dividir entre a
subíndice n que corresponde a x a la n
entre n por 5 a la n tomamos el valor
absoluto de todo esto vamos a
simplificar esto aquí abajo
esto es x a la n 1 entre el 1 por 5 a la
n 1 que multiplica al recíproco de esto
que es n por 5 a la n entre x a la n
esto lo podemos simplificar de la
siguiente manera dividimos el numerador
entre x a la n y nos queda x y dividimos
numerador y denominador entre 5 a la n
esto es 1 esto es
y esto va a ser 5 a la n 1 entre 5 a la
n va a ser igual a 5 y nos queda x por n
entre distribuimos a este 5 y nos queda
5 n 5
ahora reescribimos esto va a ser igual
al límite cuando n tiende a infinito de
el valor absoluto de esto de aquí y para
ayudarnos a calcular este límite vamos a
dividir el numerador y el denominador
entre m no estoy cambiando el valor ya
que estoy haciendo lo mismo con el
numerador y el denominador los dividimos
entre el mismo valor si / numerador y
denominador entre n esto va a ser lo
mismo que x entre 5 + 5 entre m
y cuando divido el numerador y el
denominador entre n es bastante obvio
que sucede cuando n tiende al infinito
cuando n se aproxima al infinito x no va
a cambiar 5 no va a cambiar pero 5 entre
m tiende a 0
así que este límite va a ser igual a x
entre 5
nos quedó algo bastante sencillo y ahora
vamos a usar esto el valor absoluto de x
entre 5 y vamos a analizar bajo qué
condiciones el valor absoluto de x entre
5 es menor a 1 en donde definitivamente
va a converger bajo qué condiciones será
mayor que 1 en donde definitivamente
diverge y bajo qué condiciones no vamos
a saber si convergió divergen veamos
bajo qué condiciones va a converger para
que valores de x el valor absoluto de x
entre 5 va a ser menor que 1 que es
nuestra situación de convergencia esto
es lo mismo que decir que menos 1 es
menor que x entre 5 y que a su vez éste
sea menor a 1 multiplicamos todos los
lados por 5 y nos queda menos 5 menor
que x y x menor que 5 sabemos que si
esto se cumple esto definitivamente va a
ser parte de nuestro intervalo de
convergencia si nuestra x está dentro de
este rango nuestra serie va a converger
pero
aún no terminamos tenemos que ver el
caso en el que no tenemos respuesta
pensemos en el escenario en el que el
valor absoluto de x entre 5 es igual a 1
otra forma de pensar en esto es decir
que x entre 5 es igual a 1 o que x entre
5 es igual a menos 1 lo que significa
que x es igual a 5 o x es igual a menos
5 estos son los dos casos en los que no
sabemos si converge o diverge vamos a
probarlos individualmente usando los en
nuestra serie usando x igual a 5 y x men
o 5 en el primer escenario cuando x es
igual a 5 nuestra serie va a ser la suma
desde que n es igual a 1 hasta infinito
de 5 a la n entre n por 5 a la n esto va
a ser igual a la suma desde que me es
igual a 1 hasta infinito de 1 entre n y
esta es una serie armónica es la serie p
en donde p es igual a 1 y sabemos que de
la serie es p si p es igual a 1 esto
bergé lo vimos en el vídeo de series
armónicas esto definitivamente divergen
y esto lo pueden probar con el criterio
de la convergencia de las series p
y si la p es igual a 1 para estas series
p va a divergen así que 5
definitivamente no es parte de nuestro
intervalo de convergencia ahora veamos
qué pasa cuando x es igual a menos cinco
cuando x es igual a menos 5 esto va a
ser igual a la suma desde que n es igual
a 1 hasta infinito de menos 5 a la n
entre n por 5 a la n esto es igual a la
suma desde que n es igual a 1 hasta
infinito y esto podemos escribirlo como
menos 1 a la n por 5 a la n entre n por
5 a la n esto se cancela y nos queda una
serie alternante y quizás sepan que esto
convergen o pueden usar el criterio de
las series alternantes y este criterio
de las series alternantes en este
criterio si vemos que esto se decremento
a mono tónica
y el límite cuando n se aproxima al
infinito es 0 esto va a converger las
series armónicas alternantes convergen y
ya que esto convergen podemos incluirlo
en nuestro límite aquí en nuestro
intervalo de convergencia así que x no
tiene que ser estrictamente mayor que
menos 5 puede ser mayor o igual que
menos 5 pero tiene que ser menor que 5 y
así encontramos nuestro intervalo de
convergencia